okay I know why you're happy I know I
know I know thank you I know why
I know why it stopped raining we had a
lot of rain but that was right
California had rain
so much half the state this is out of
the drought and uh Governor newsom's
really leaning into it his new campaign
slogan is Newsom he'll make you wet
the ladies know what I'm talking about
also uh Tuesday a couple of days ago the
California's covert emergency ended so
that's nice
so if you have a friend who is still
living like a prisoner it's because they
tried to quit Scientology that's
what you do with covert anymore
yeah covet big in the news there the
department of energy said that they uh
think it was most likely that it did
come from the lab the Wuhan lab I mean
this has been a I've said from the
beginning should not be political let's
just find out the science but that's
what the FBI says that some people say
that it could have leaked from the lab
and uh this is a big story The the
manager at the Wuhan bat on a stick
today said
where do I go to get my reputation back
you know
what
we don't know stop politicizing
everything we're so arrogant they know
you don't know nobody knows even
the department of energy which said they
think this is that they said we were
reporting this with low confidence
then why say anything low confidence
well you know what you work for the
government we have that for you too okay
uh
what what does that mean so what they
were staring at their shoes when they
said it we
um we think I might have
might have come from the lab but you
know I don't know we got a lot of
wrong with it what is it babe talking
like a valley girl
um it came from the lab
um and then people got sick and stuff
on our government so you know the
Republicans have taken over the house
now so the Ethics Committee there uh
they're investigating AOC because of
that dress she wore at the Met Gala
remember that of the tax the rich dress
there's something about improper gifts
or whatever it is
younger viewers who are watching this
show
might need to know that this is not the
first time the Democrats have had a
scandal that involved a dress with
something on it
[Applause]
so here's a real schedule now Ron
DeSantis who could be the Republican
nominee he's out in California this
weekend working the crowd back in his
home state of Florida a Republican
representative there is trying to make
bloggers register if they write
about Republicans okay I have some real
mixed feelings about this one this is an
outrageous violation of the free speech
on the other hand I hate bloggers so
but uh
DeSantis is skipping CPAC that's the big
Republican well I guess it's
conservative but it's all Republicans of
course convention they have every year
but of course the big star
guess who
yes Donald Trump spoke it's in Maryland
and I don't get this about Republicans
they they wheel out this grotesque
peroxide blonde
under five pounds of makeup but the
thing they're most upset about is drag
queen Story Hour I I I don't get that